well good evening Fernando welcome to
Piers Morgan uncensored for a man who
reveres his privacy Prince Harry
certainly has a knack for making himself
the center of global attention
this is a show for Fearless debate so
let's have a Fearless debate about
Prince privacy Harry is seemingly
addicted
to invading his privacy invading the
privacy of his friends and families and
appearing in public places and making
sure that everyone talks about them he's
currently at the high court in London
he's flown 5 000 miles which is a good
thing to do if you're an Eco Warrior of
course watching your carbon footprint to
attend a case which involves the owners
of a Daily Mail newspaper accusing them
of breaching his privacy is one of many
celebrities that are down there number
stage of a court case is all about
procedure there are no Witnesses no
evidence no box of this material the
hearings take place today and yesterday
and could have passed without anyone
really noticing but Harry wanted
everyone to see him uh he wanted to make
the front page news and he arrived uh
turning up with a big grin on his face
and leaving with a big girl on his face
looking like he's rather enjoying it all
which is probably not the best look for
someone who's wanting us to believe that
he's in trauma because of the invasion
into his privacy which came just before
his own grotesque invasion of other
people's privacy
um so it's a little bit complicated
isn't it and he didn't step in quietly
through the side entrance it's like some
of the others involved in this case he
chose to parade past the TV cameras
barging past some Paparazzi and marched
through the front Gates using the media
that he loves to invade his privacy
you see the problem here and he's loving
it look at him it's grinning away what a
laugh
nothing better than the cost of living
crisis and watching multi-millionaires
rocking up in court wanting money for
invasions of privacy just after they've
invaded their own so Harry for me to be
rather confused about his treatment by
the media it's almost like he wants to
keep his privacy so he can invade it
when he's invading everybody else's even
our fair-minded peers on neighboring
networks appeared have woken up and
sniffed the hypocritical coffee
he has been taking lots of notes again
today there's no need for him to be here
because all of the evidence that's being
presented on behalf of the claimants is
written and so it really is the fact
that he's appeared today was about sort
of being seen publicly
of course well Harry's hatred of the
media was laid Baron 6000 media bashing
for Netflix which ironically is the same
Media company that just happens to paid
him 100 million dollars and of course is
also airing the crown which invades the
privacy of his entire family on a
minute-by-minute basis and often grow
testably mischaracterizes the truth but
no matter there's money so he'll keep
quiet about that but there's a major
flaw also in Harry's campaign against
press invasions of the Privacy is this
he's made his own privacy a ruthless
public commodity trading in his secrets
and those of his family and his friends
and sometimes even the people he lost
his virginity to to the highest bidders
the prince who fled Britain to protect
apparently his family's privacy as laid
bare every taudry detail of his private
life and theirs in this tell-all Memoir
from drug abuse to intimate
conversations with his father the king
at his grandfather's funeral he gave
exclusive access to images of his
children to the Netflix cameras he
taught TV studios discussing his frost
bitten todger to sell copies of his book
he charged Royal watches 30 each to
watch a live stream of a therapy session
in which she again boasted about his
drug use how much self-destruction of
your own privacy can a public figure get
away with before they abrogate their
right to privacy but privacy isn't
really at the heart of Harry's Crusade
he's made that Crystal Clear by selling
it to the highest bidders now what Harry
really wants is control he can control
the narrative in Netflix shows he can
control the questions he's asked in
publicity jumpers he can't control his
version of the truth in his book
or books what he cannot control is a
free press and yet a free press warts
and all good bad and ugly are the type
we have in this country is the very
Cornerstone of a democracy and that's
why Harry who wants complete control
over everything that said and written
about him is so afraid of our Free Press
would you let me know as a broadcaster
Joseph Godard and professor of politics
and author Matt Goodwin okay Patricia
you're the case for the defense off you
go
um and why am I wrong about this point I
don't want to get into my new side of
the individual cases one of them
involves the mirror group I'm gonna I'm
sure he'll have a girl whack at me while
he's doing it I don't want to get into
that because we can't for the legal
reasons however on the general point I'm
making which is yeah of course as a
member of the royal family he's had his
private life raked over the goals for
decades of course they all have and in
return
the others all accept that the deal is
you get the Palaces the servants the
fancy life you're the biggest stars in
the world and the oppressor like an
annoying Buzzard on the backside of a
bison
um Harry sees it in a much more
malevolent way but then of course comes
the hypocrisy of the book The Netflix
series everything else where he seems to
just be relentlessly invading his own
privacy that of his family that of his
friends a lot of other people he's met
on his on his life how can you have your
cake your privacy cake and eat it well
I'm in a difficult position because I
could say to a much lesser degree and
I'm nothing like Harry as far as profile
is concerned but I would be the same
because for instance when I was in
hospital in 2008 I think you know one of
the reasons I moved to the States was I
didn't have any privacy there I didn't
have privacy when I was in hospital I
had journalists trying to pretend to
deliver flowers my kids had to go
through security and what have you now
I'd written a book about my life and I
talked about my life in minutia and yet
there was a line I didn't think it was
fair to cross now we all have our own
lines and our own boundaries and they
met might not make sense to other people
but I think as you're right you're right
in that if we feel we're controlling the
narrative if I wanted to talk about my
Hospital experience which I did to a
certain amount of drinking that's fine
if somebody wants to be under hand and
pretend to be delivering flowers and get
surreptitious pictures of me when I'm
going through chemotherapy that is
something else so I think this whole
court case it I think is the difference
between queen Harry having and you're
right their control
an underhand alleged underhand methods
of people getting another narrow
narrative I think we all have a public
face we all have a private Faith okay uh
Matthew you win your response to this
does Harry have any right to privacy now
can he go and have court battles over
his private life given what he's now
done to his private lives well I think
as a couple they've made a conscious
decision to put themselves out there and
I think there's something else that
Harry can't control which is what do
people think about him and if you look
at the polls on Harry and Megan and I
spent a lot of my time looking at the
polls well I've never seen a brand
collapse this hard this quickly since
the end of last year both Harry and
Megan are down 40 points we've just had
a poll In America which shows he's less
popular now than prince Andrew in
America so as a brand I think
anecdotally I've been bouncing this
latest thing off people and they're like
get me straight he's going all the way
from La for a a part of the process he
doesn't need to be at just to be in the
papers going through the front entrance
and he's laughing yeah what kind of
thing is is he thinking he's
representing here what image is he
putting forward I think they think
they're The Underdogs going up against
the system the public won't see that but
the cost of living crisis we haven't had
in 100 years I think there's any going
to be any sympathy honestly I don't
thought
is he looking for sympathy I mean he's
not the only one who's made of Avengers
but well he's not the only one who's
very visible in this and as you
mentioned there are other people David
Furniture
Doreen Lawrence if Doreen Lawrence is
pretty much saying exactly the same
thing as Harry and I'm sorry with Doreen
Lawrence that infuriates me now
everybody is saying the same thing well
under in-laws we are pretty much we have
to be clear that the male have issued a
robust day absolutely denial of all
these allegations and in particular
about Doreen I agree and there is a
messy situation involving some of the
West muscle blowers now recounting what
they set so let's wait and see how this
is what I'm saying is what the people
what they're saying what they're
claiming is fairly similar but you know
David finished all the rest of them
um so I think it is it is about control
and when you say about him laughing as
he goes into court I don't know why but
it brings to mind somebody else's Sue
Ella Braven been laughing in Rwanda I
mean some yeah inappropriate sometimes
people do stupid things in serious
situations there's also a sadness here
isn't it Matthew and it is a sadness
because he's over here and he's flown
all this way to go and have his little
moment in in the in the court and in the
papers because he hates the president
but he's not being seen by any of his
family it's been reported his father
doesn't want to see him his brother
doesn't want to see we don't know that
well it's been reported by the telegraph
he's pretty plugged into the Royals the
King has no room in his schedule right
if my son flew 5 000 miles uh to the
city I was in I'd be seeing my sons any
of them right so this is clearly a
massive Rift here apparently he and
Megan haven't even said if they'll go to
the coronation I don't know why who they
think they are to be keeping the king
waiting on whether they come or not but
it just seems again the priorities are
completely warped here yeah I feel sorry
for Harry actually I think he's a deeply
Disturbed
um young man who needs a lot of support
and I think if you look at the therapy
session that he did in the U.S that is
not something that I think somebody who
is completely in command of their you
know of of themselves and is getting
good advice from public relations people
has a supportive team around them I
don't think that's something that that a
person like that would do so when I look
at him I see someone actually who's
quite lost Trisha yeah I agree with you
you're an expert in people right
I tell you you've always been you've
always been great at giving people
advice no I agree I actually agree with
Matthew I think the people around him
have given him crap advice yeah whatever
I agree really do and and also because
there's a disconnect the people around
him a lot of them are Americans let's be
closely clear about when you say that
look I think the main driver of a lot of
this is Megan as well
she's an American who's probably got
exactly what she wants out of it she's
back in living in the state she grew up
in a massive mansion with hundreds of
millions
about the royal family or I don't I
don't know
but I don't know whether that is or not
but I'm coming back to Matthew's point
the people around him we all come up
with stupid ideas from now and again if
you're in the median somebody says oh
come on shut up there is nobody around
he's got a lot of enablers and they're
fueling his kind of Perpetual victimhood
And yet when I watched him marching into
court the last couple of those I don't
see a victim at all I see a very I see a
victim do you I see a victim of
circumstance of to Echo youth of tragedy
of pain of of not wearing knowing where
they are of being lost and there's many
people in men how much can you milk yeah
I see when you you're actually born into
gigantic privilege and when so many
millions of people are going through
genuine life or death hardship right now
I just think there is a very limited
pool of sympathy for Prince Harry right
now in this country for watching him
take on the media again and railing
about privacy people like hang on hasn't
he just done a book about all his
private life yeah I see a symbol of
everything that's wrong with our culture
and to be honest everything that's wrong
with well you've written a good book
about it values voice and virtue which
touches on a lot of this right yeah so
basically it's about how we got here as
a country how have we gone through the
last 10 years of political turbulence
and my argument in a nutshell is we now
have a new Elite in this country that
has become dangerously disconnected from
the values that are held by most people
out there who feel that they don't have
a voice in the conversation and they're
looking at this Elite embracing this
radical woke ideology and they're saying
well what on Earth is this and why do
you keep undermining the things I love
like the institution well I completely
agree you're shaking your head but I
think instinctively you know bit of
truth to this did this woke stuff
completely I hate the misuse we're
journalists though let's not misuse the
word woke for what it was let's call it
I don't know what you want to call it
but young people I think they're not
just young people I think there's a
disconnect between the I agree there's a
disconnect
um I think I'm generalizing here between
youth between Generations which isn't
very different from the days of Bill
Haley and the Rockers and what have you
but there is a you know whoa to me is a
word that people use when they it's like
a catch-all and it's all nearly always
misused I would say there's a disconnect
between the when you call them the lead
I'd say the the politicians it's not
just the politicians anymore no at the
moment for the last 10 years we've had
the same political people in power so if
you're gonna moan about immigration and
everything else
I also think though we've become as a
society pathetically weak and we now
celebrate victimhood and we celebrate
weakness over strength and winning and
ambition and aspiration and it's making
us a weak Society I really do believe
that I don't think I think we are
honestly I don't think I think there's
and I think are they carrying away
personifies he's always privilege all
this money he went for Freedom he
doesn't seem happy other than what he's
taking on the media and it's like really
just get over yourself mate get on with
your happy life in California stay with
your chickens drop drop the Royal titles
because why would you want titles given
to you by an institution you ate so much
right drop it all and then you give your
kids the time so I mean come on the
whole thing is riddle with hypocrisy
anyway thank you happy to see Matthew
coming back a little bit later thank you
very much